The thing that's made RStudio, and now
Posit, so amazing is the community.
We love and value our open source community
and we're so appreciative of everyone who's
helped make Posit what it is today.
And ourcommunity is YOU!
You live and work on everycontinent.
And one of the most used datasets for
teaching is even from Antarctica.
You use R for school or work or fun, answering
questions that are important to you.
You work onprojects in education, science, marketing, public
health, government, economics, finance, libraries,
astronomy and so, so much more. You create and
share thousands of resources to help others.
You contribute to code and documentation on
hundreds of Open Source projects. You're involved
in the community, sharing with each other in your
organizations and in user groups around the world.
And, of course, you write millions of lines of
code. Thanks to you, R is one of today's top
10 programming languages. I've been using R for
almost 20 years now, and the transformation of the
language and the community just blows my mind.
I'm so awed and grateful for all that we have
built together. And I, and everyone at Posit,
wishes you all the best for the coming year.